[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers hallo
und ihnen allen einen guten abend das
ist sehr viel teurer wird in deutschland
war bereits klar seit heute gibt es
nähere details da sind zum einen die
gestiegenen energiekosten die viele von
uns erst wirklich merken werden wenn die
nächste nebenkostenabrechnung kommt aber
dann werden wir sie merken und zwar
richtig
unabhängig davon kommt noch eine umlage
dazu die der staat allen gaskunden
auferlegt um damit die ins straucheln
gekommenen gasimporteure zu stützen die
genaue höhe ist noch offen sie wird laut
wirtschaftsminister liegen zwischen 1,5
und 5 cent je kilowattstunde
schauen wir uns doch mal im detail an
wenn man jetzt einen klassischen
vier-personen-haushalt mit 20.000
kilowattstunden jahresverbrauch zugrunde
legt dann wären das inklusive
mehrwertsteuer zwischen
357 und
1190 euro im jahr extra wie gesagt
zusätzlich zur gasrechnung des
versorgers was dagegen hilft sparen wie
das am besten geht so sonnt ina
welche kosten wegen der gras umlage
zusätzlich auf sie zukommen könnten sie
noch nicht abschätzen sagen daniel und
mara kirberg aber dass die preise
nochmals steigen sollen habe sie sehr
überrascht umzurüsten um energiekosten
zu senken finden sie wichtig und wenn es
zum beispiel ums dämmen geht könnten sie
vieles selbst machen da sind ja die
kosten verhältnismäßig noch noch gering
noch tragbar und wir hoffen uns dann
davon dass wir tatsächlich vielleicht
nach ein oder zwei jahren sich die die
kosten schon wieder drin haben hoher
besuch im heizungskeller hessens
wirtschaftsminister tarik al wazirs
zurzeit im land unterwegs um energiespar
tipps zu geben heute traf er sich mit
familie kirberg einer energie beraterin
und der vermieterin es gibt einiges zu
tun
die ungedämmte heizungsrohre und die
ungedämmte kellerdecke und ich habe von
dem mieter erfahren dass ein
hydraulischer abgleich noch nicht
durchgeführt wurde weil hier gerade
kürzlich eine neue therme eingebaut
wurde ist davon auszugehen dass bis zu
30 prozent weniger energiekosten
entstehen werden wenn sie sich dass
allein in hessen anschauen werden hier
drei millionen haushalte wenn alle diese
haushalte durch kleine maßnahmen ihren
energieverbrauch um 10 15 prozent
reduzieren können dann macht das in der
summe echt eine menge aus und das genau
könnte den unterschied machen bei der
frage kommen wir über diesen winter auch
ohne russisches gas oder schaffen wir
das nicht um die frage ist aber auch wer
soll das bezahlen
eine wärmepumpe neue fenster oder
heizungen können teuer werden es gibt
zwar förderungen aber man muss vorlegen
und der größte anteil ist selbst zu
zahlen hier sind absolut dafür dass man
solche sachen im meer auf fördert damit
eben auch diejenigen die das machen
wollen aber nicht das kapital haben das
tun können denken sie nur zum beispiel
daran dass viele eigenheimbesitzer auch
schon älter sind sie können also mit
privaten krediten kaum rechnen weil
banken eigentlich schon fast über 70
dann keine kredite mehr vergeben das
heißt da muss eine förderung her das ist
teuer und gas ist knapp der russische
präsident putin cup das für deutschland
immer mehr und händeringend wird jetzt
nach alternativen gesucht der digital
verband bitkom die großes potenzial in
den rund 3000 rechenzentren in
deutschland 90 davon seien ausreichend
groß und ihre abwärme bestens geeignet
um diese 90 rechnet alleine könnten
350.000 haushalte das ganze jahr über
heizen und diese möglichkeit wird im
moment nicht genutzt um die
möglichkeiten zu nutzen bedarf es folgen
das wir brauchen im prinzip ein ausbau
der fernwärmenetze wir brauchen extra
wärmetauscher die temperatur erhöhen und
dazu müsste natürlich auch das thema
nazi entgelt gelöst werden es heute
unentgeltlich sein weil wir sparen jetzt
so eine menge energie ein fest steht es
gibt in deutschland nicht nur ein
problem mit gas sondern auch mit
handwerkern die fehlen nämlich mara und
daniel kirberg müssen nicht auf
handwerker warten sie wollen sich um die
dämmung der heizungsrohre und der
kellerdecke so schnell wie möglich
selbst kümmern
im heute-journal update um 0.30 fragen
dazu an einen experten der denkfabrik
agora energiewende die sanktionen gegen
russland sollen russland härter treffen
als uns selbst das war der plan und es
gab ja mal eine zeit da konnten die
sanktionen vielen nicht schnell genug
gehen und hart genug ausfallen so groß
war der schock und das entsetzen über
den fürchterlichen krieg des russischen
präsidenten gegen die ukraine ich sage
deshalb war weil der krieg zwar um mit
unvermindert weitergeht bei den
sanktionen das bild aber mittlerweile
etwas anders aussieht europas
chefdiplomat bekommt in eu-hauptstädten
mittlerweile auch deutliche zweifel an
der sanktionspolitik gegen russland zu
hören und das wort fehler da gerät
offenbar etwas ins rutschen in sachen
europäischer solidarität und dabei ist
der ungar viktor orban noch gar nicht
eingerechnet der sich immer massiver und
radikaler gegen seine eu partner stellt
florian a
da treffen sich heute zwei
regierungschefs einer aufgeklärten
demokratischen wertegemeinschaft der eu
oder halt nein da treffen sich ein
demokrat aus österreich und viktor orban
aus ungarn ein ja was denn nun
er ist jetzt schon ein anti demokraten
anti-europäer und jetzt zeigt sich eben
ganz offen dass er auch ein ein rassist
ist und dass er keine scheu hat sich bei
faschistischem gedankengut zu bedienen
mal wieder hat man dieser tage eine
grenze überschritten samstag der
ungarische ministerpräsident warnt vor
einer welt in der sich die europäischen
völker mit den ankömmlingen von
außerhalb europas vermischen wir wollen
nicht zu gemischtrassigen werden es
klingt wie die sprache der nazis wird
heute sogar von der holocaust
gedenkstätte yad vashem aus israel
kritisiert nur von orban selbst weiter
verteidigt
ich möchte nicht dass die migration in
ungarn stärker wird diesen standpunkt
habe ich stets vertreten das werde ich
auch künftig tun
das hat keine biologischen grundlagen
das ist keine rassistische frage das ist
eine frage der kultur
schweigen bei den eu spitzen von einer
vorsichtigen distanzierung des
österreichischen bundeskanzlers nie
haben wir einmal abgesehen was mich am
meisten wundern und wo ich auch die eu
staats und regierungschefs kritisieren
würde ist dass sie
eben keine roten linien selbst haben und
es immer wieder akzeptieren sind nicht
das erste mal dass orban rote linien
überschreitet er blockiert auch immer
zunehmend die
entscheidungen im europäischen rat baden
gegen alle gerade in der russland
politik ist dass die übliche brüsseler
geschichte dieser tage das öl-embargo
blockiert er zunächst beim gas
notfallplan wird sein vito überstimmt
und seinen außenminister schickt der
nach moskau der dort um mehr russisches
gas bittet es ist schon natürlich auch
teil der wünsche von hand putin die eu
auseinander zu dividieren und er
leistete auch wenn leider im sinne
putins auch einen beitrag zur ganzen
wahrheit aber gehört auch dass sich
hinter der totalblockade aus ungarn
längst andere zweifler quer durch europa
melden nicht so aus wie orban aber auch
längst nicht mehr so überzeugt von den
sanktionen wie noch zu beginn
manche europäischen staats und
regierungschefs haben gesagt die
sanktionen waren ein fehler ich glaube
nicht dass sie einen fehler waren es war
was wir tun mussten und wir werden es
weiter tun
für alles weitere aber das wissen sie in
europa brauchen sie die zustimmung auch
von viktor orban vielleicht ist die
kritik an ihm auch deshalb so leise
fragen wir nochmal nach florian guten
abend diese zweifel an den sanktionen
die der eu chefdiplomatin manchen
hauptstädten mittlerweile ausmacht kann
das sogar dazu führen dass die
sanktionen wieder zurückgenommen werden
obwohl sich am krieg ja nichts geändert
hat ja offiziell zurück nehmen das wäre
schon ein harter schritt den man sich
sicher nicht trauen wird aber wir
stellen auch hier in brüssel fest dass
sich der diskurs dramatisch gewandelt
hat das eben längst nicht mehr alle
überzeugt sind von diesen sanktionen es
gab da mal ein automatismus in dieser
krise dass nach dem einen sanktionspaket
sofort das nächste geredet wird nach dem
letzten gipfel haben da viele staats und
regierungschefs ein stoppschild gesetzen
gesagt es gebe jetzt vorerst kein
weiteres mehr das liegt natürlich vor
allem darin dass auch die bisherigen
noch nicht mal ganz umgesetzt sind etwa
in der energiepolitik da haben wir zwei
embargos beschlossen und verkündet aus
europa auf russische crew kohle und auf
russisches öl aber erstens sind eben
beide nicht vollständig in kraft gesetzt
russisches öl wird weiterhin bezogen bis
ende dieses jahres zweitens fürchten
viele regierungen da weiter an den
wachsenden unmut in der eigenen
bevölkerung wegen steigender
energiepreise und drittens ist es so
dass man auch hier in brüssel eine
gewisse resignation spürt bei manchen
regierungen dass die sanktionen eben
doch nicht so schnell wirken wie von
manchen anfangs erhofft europa merkt
dass man hier einen langen atem braucht
eine sehr viel längere ausdauer als zu
anfang noch gedacht interessante analyse
florian herzlichen dank dir dafür heute
abend nach brüssel der krieg in der
ukraine verschlimmert auch eine
katastrophe die sich abseits der ganz
großen schlagzeilen abspielt wo sie aber
dringend hingehört einfach weil das was
dort geschieht jetzt im moment jeden tag
neu eine schande ist für diese welt wir
zeigen ihnen jetzt bilder die schwer zu
ertragen sind bilder von kleinen kindern
von babys die viel zu lange schon nichts
mehr zu essen hatten die zu schwach sind
um zu weinen die sterben die zahl der
menschen die in somalia im osten afrikas
schwer unterernährt sind hat sich in den
letzten sechs monaten verdreifacht einer
viertelmillion menschen droht
unmittelbar der tod weil seit vier
jahren kein regen kam und jetzt
viel zu wenig hilfe peter smith und
kamran safi arian berichten
sie sind seit tagen unterwegs
verzweifelte menschen auf der suche nach
essen und trinken müde erschöpft
ausgehungert ihre dörfer sind hunderte
kilometer entfernt
fátima musste mit ansehen wie eines
ihrer kinder verhungert jetzt droht im
nächsten kind der hungertod
mein kind verhungert es übergibt sich
hat durchfall fieber und ist
unterernährt
das lager kh rebollo invest somalia am
anfang des jahres waren hier 60.000
menschen jetzt sind es
146.000 viele hoffen hier dem hungertod
zu entkommen es trifft die schwächsten
die akutesten fälle werden auf dieser
station stabilisiert
die liga ist stark unterernährt sie ist
vier hat das gewicht einer einjährigen
diesmal ist gerade ein jahr alt geworden
ohne behandlung wäre er längst tot die
hälfte aller somalischen kinder ist
unterernährt jeden tag stirbt in somalia
ein kind das medizinische team prüft
anzeichen von unterernährung
dieser junge ist im roten bereich
wir brauchen einfach noch mehr
nahrungsmittel das ist das wichtigste
eine behandlung einfach nur mit
medikamenten reicht nicht aus und der
ernährung begünstigt auch krankheiten
wie cholera oder tuberkulose ali muss
bereits sein viertes kind begraben
mein sohn wurde krank er hatte durchfall
und bauchweh dann hört er einfach auf zu
essen
grund für die hungersnot ist die
schwerste dürre seit jahrzehnten viermal
hintereinander gab es in der regenzeit
keinen regen verlassene häuser kaputte
felder das vieh lebensgrundlage vieler
menschen verändert
alle rinder zu hause sind tot die
brunnen ausgetrocknet einige von uns
waren so schwach vor hunger dass wir sie
zurücklassen mussten
schlimmer noch somalia bezug mehr als 90
prozent seines weizens aus russland und
der ukraine doch jetzt sind die
lieferwege blockiert die preise
explodiert die vereinten nationen warnen
vor einem massen
das ist nicht nur eine weitere
dürreperiode das ist die schlimmste
dürre seit 40 jahren und die welt muss
ihre aufmerksamkeit auf somalia richten
wegen des verheerenden ausmaßes der not
mit jedem tag wächst die zahl derer die
es nicht schaffen
unterdessen kommen immer mehr menschen
im lager an eine frau bricht zusammen
sie hat auf dem weg ein kind zur welt
gebracht und ist danach noch fünf
kilometer gelaufen
es ist ein junge ist gesund wie lange
noch
sie können nichts für den zustand dieser
welt aber sie bezahlen den höchsten
preis
anna du guckst jetzt auf die aktuelle
lage in der ukraine
dort werden die kämpfe weiter
fortgesetzt und erstmals seit wochen
wurden dabei auch wieder die lange
verschwunden regionen kiew und cherry
hill vom russischen militär beschossen
in carson machte die ukraine unterdessen
bei einer gegenoffensive fortschritte
das berichtet der britische militär
geheimdienst so sei es dem ukrainischen
militär gelungen mindestens drei brücken
zu beschädigen die für den russischen
nachschub wichtig sind
bundesaußenministerium berbalk ist nach
griechenland gereist und wird morgen
außerdem die türkei besuchen dabei
stehen neben dem ukraine krieg auch die
spannungen zwischen den beiden nato
ländern im fokus griechenland und die
türkei streiten schon lange über
erdgasvorkommen im mittelmeer in athen
erinnerte baerbock außerdem an die
gräueltaten der deutschen besatzung im
zweiten weltkrieg forderungen nach
entschädigungszahlungen
die aussenministerin zurück
cdu-chef merz hat in polen
ministerpräsidentin uhr ab jetzt
getroffen und mit diesem über die
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine zu
sprechen hintergrund sind verstimmungen
in der polnischen regierung wegen
problemen beim waffen ringtausch mit
deutschland märz ist mit seinem besuch
der bundesregierung zuvor gekommen
der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten weiter lücke ist
seit heute thema vor dem
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe im januar
2021 war der rechtsextremist stefan
ernst wegen mordes zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt worden der mitangeklagte
markus h wurde vom vorwurf der beihilfe
freigesprochen
gegen das urteil legten alle
prozessbeteiligten revision ein deshalb
prüft jetzt der bundesgerichtshof auf
rechtsfehler eine entscheidung wird ende
august erwartet weiter lücke war im
sommer 2009 10 auf der terrasse seines
hauses erschossen worden
die weltbevölkerung hat nach
berechnungen der internationalen
organisation global footprint network
heute den sogenannten ehrt überlastung
stuck erreicht also den zeitpunkt an dem
die menschen weltweit alle ressourcen
aufgebraucht haben die der planet in
einem jahr auf natürlichem weg ersetzen
könnte in vielen industrieländern war
der errechnete tag sogar schon früher
bei uns in deutschland am vierten mai
es ist die hitze aber vor allem ist es
die trockenheit in den waldbrandgebieten
brandenburg und sachsen kämpfen hunderte
feuerwehrleute gegen immer wieder
aufflammende glutnester
mittlerweile den vierten tag in folge
der wind hat gedreht und die lage in der
sächsischen schweiz verschärft es ist
schwer löschwasser in die betroffenen
gebiete zu bekommen umso wichtiger sind
hubschrauber im feuerwehreinsatz aber
die elbe wo sie wasser aufnehmen sollen
hat derzeit selbst viel zu wenig davon
so wie viele flüsse in deutschland klein
wasser heißt das bei den binnenschiffern
auf dem rhein die deshalb nicht mehr
voll beladen fahren können eine weitere
hiobsbotschaft gerade für unternehmen
die auf die schiffsfracht angewiesen
sind es ist wie beim domino einstein
lässt die nächsten kippen lothar becker
1000 tonnen hafer für die vt in müllen
werke firmenchef robert lamers hätte
gern mehr in rotterdam gekauft doch mehr
kann mit einem schiff derzeit nicht nach
düsseldorf gefahren werden aufgrund des
niedrigen pegelstand des rheins
stattdessen werden 150 prozent
niedrigwasser zuschlag fällig wenn der
normale fragt 10.000 euro wer bezahlt
ich jetzt den 1000 euro fracht 15.000
euro nochmal zuschlag das heißt unterm
strich liegt bei 25.000 euro anstatt für
10.000 euro die wahre natur zurück zu
bekommen
dabei ist die lage am niederrhein noch
relativ entspannt das nadelöhr des
rheins liegt 200 kilometer stromaufwärts
bei coop dort ist das wasser derzeit
besonders niedrig um hier nicht auf
grund zu laufen hat binnenschiffer leo
doms nicht mal ein drittel seiner
ladekapazität an bord mit 1100 statt
3900 tonnen geht es für ihn und seine
frau maria von ludwigshafen nach
amsterdam vielleicht kleinere schiffe
können noch ein meter länge dann hoch
war aber von uns ist mit
30 40 zentimeter der ist dann ist
schluss und schon jetzt fehlt an manchen
stellen so viel wasser dass gerade mal
eine getränkekiste zwischen schiffsrumpf
und rein sohle passen zwar ist nutzbarer
frachtraum bei niedrigwasser immer knapp
doch diesmal verschärfen weitere
faktoren die situation
wir wissen ja alle dass die
kohleverstromung wieder aufgenommen wird
das heißt ein großteil der kapazitäten
wird benötigt um kohle zu transportieren
weiterer binnenschiffs raum wird in die
donau verbracht um dort der ukraine beim
getreide exporthilfen durch den ukraine
krieg sind auch die kosten für energie
und getreide in robert lasshofer mühle
in düsseldorf enorm gestiegen bei der
anlieferung allerdings gibt es wohl
keine alternative zum binnenschiff mit
der bahn haben wir tatsächlich
alternativ nach dem niedrigwasser 20 18
gerechnet es ist noch viel teurer weil
man niedrigwasser nicht planen kann ich
müsste das ganze jahr über waggons
vorhalten nieten und weiß gar nicht ob
ich sie brauche lkws ist natürlich dann
auch eine ökologische frage um ein
binnenschiff was wir pro woche bekommen
zu ersetzen brauche ich 140 lkw bis der
rhein auf möglicherweise häufigere
niedrigwasser phasen eingestellt und
ausgebaut ist können noch jahre wenn
nicht jahrzehnte ins land gehen und so
dürften preissteigerungen aufgrund
sinkender pegelstände auch künftig eher
die regel bleiben
ein weiteres beispiel dafür wie alles
mit allem zusammenhängt die klimakrise
und der flusspegel der flusspegel und
die lieferketten und noch etwas hängt
zusammen hohe energiepreise und große
sorgen bei den einen hohe energiepreise
und große gewinne bei den anderen anna
und da schauen wir zuallererst auf die
sorgen die inflation in deutschland
bleibt weiter auf hohem niveau 75
prozent schätzt das statistische
bundesamt für juli allerdings ist das
der zweite leichte rückgang in folge
stephanie beckert und das macht
natürlich hoffnung dass die inflation
nachhaltig an tempo verlieren könnte
dies das einzuschätzen ja das ist
wirklich die frage die große frage hanna
ob wir jetzt schon den scheitelpunkt
erreicht haben wahrscheinlich aber noch
nicht denn im september da laufen die
inflation dämpfen den maßnahmen wie tank
rabatt und neun euro ticket ja aus und
dann könnte die inflation durchaus auch
noch mal über acht prozent springen
allerdings dürfte sich das tempo
verlangsamen morgen früh da wissen wir
mehr wenn nämlich die quartalszahlen für
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung
verkündet werden experten rechnen da
allenfalls noch mit einem mini-wachstum
zugleich halten die verbraucher sich
jetzt schon beim einkaufen zurück das
geld zusammen das heißt die nachfrage
geht zurück und die preise könnten
wieder sinken von entwarnung kann also
keine rede sein denn auch der preisschub
bei lebensmitteln hat mit 15 prozent
schon beunruhigende maßnahmen oder
ausmaße erreicht ganz zu schweigen von
den energiepreisen hier ist auf
absehbare zeit auch kein ende der
teuerung in sicht es gibt aber auch
absolute krisengewinner die von den
hohen energiepreisen profitieren bei
shell und co klingeln die kassen oh ja
die mineralölgesellschaften zählen
insbesondere seitdem ukraine krieg zu
den großen krisengewinnern und machen
ordentlich kasse denn russisches öl ist
wegen der sanktionen ja knapper geworden
das hat den ölpreis am weltmarkt nach
oben getrieben auch die gewinnspannen
der raffinerien sind enorm gestiegen
weil einfach viele in den letzten jahren
geschlossen wurden man wollte ja weg von
fossilen energieträgern öl und vor allem
verdienen die ölmultis ganz gewaltig an
ihrem eigenen handel mit strom und gas
in nur drei monaten hat europas größter
ölkonzern
shell satte sechs milliarden euro mehr
verdient als im vorjahresquartal und
damit seinen gewinn ebenso verdoppelt
wie der französische energieriese total
energy und der spanische öl multi repsol
kein zweifel die mineralölkonzerne
verdienen prächtig das dürfte die
debatte um eine beteiligung der ölmultis
an der entlastung von industrie und
verbrauchern in deutschland wieder
befeuern einige europäische länder
bitten die ölkonzerne ja bereits mit
sonder steuern zur kasse andere planen
es noch denn die eu-kommission hat
immerhin bereits grünes licht gegeben
für eine solche zeitlich begrenzte über
gewinnen steuer vielen dank stefanie für
diese einschätzung
die deutsche bahn schreibt nach zwei
verlustjahren wieder schwarze zahlen im
ersten halbjahr konnte der staatskonzern
einen operativen gewinn von 876
millionen euro erzielen zu verdanken hat
die bahn das vor allem dem
milliardengewinn ihrer logistiktochter
db schenker zudem stieg die zahl der
reisenden nach dem corona tief wieder
deutlich den fernverkehr nutzen demnach
rund 59 millionen reisende das sind mehr
als doppelt so viele wie im
vorjahreszeitraum
53 siege vier weltmeistertitel und jetzt
ist schluss sebastian vettel einer der
erfolgreichsten rennfahrer der
formel-1-geschichte beendet seine
karriere nach dieser saison
er wolle mehr zeit für seine familie
haben erklärte der 35 jährige in einer
videobotschaft
in seiner zeit bei red bull gelangen dem
heppenheimer gleich vier titel in folge
weder bei ferrari noch bei aston martin
konnte er an alte erfolge anknüpfen
zuletzt setzte sich vettel immer mehr
für klimaschutz und menschenrechte ein
musik hilft nicht beim vergessen denn
sie wollen gar nicht vergessen musik
hilft aber beim orientieren habe etwas
von einer psychotherapie sagen die
musikerinnen und musiker die heute abend
in warschau eine besondere premiere
feiern zehn tage intensive proben liegen
hinter ihnen das ist wahnsinnig wenig
zeit für ein orchester das weltweit auf
tour gehen will zumal viele mitglieder
vorher noch nie miteinander gespielt
haben aber sie haben etwas anderes was
sie zusammenführt alle stammen aus der
ukraine und sie spielen für die freiheit
sechs neue welt trifft auf ein neu
zusammengesetztes orchester
berufsmusiker die sonst in verschiedenen
philharmonien in aller welt spielen
proben das allererste mal zusammen und
sind doch schon lange eng miteinander
verbunden
[Musik]
franz wir sind eine freunde wir sind
brüder aus demselben land
sprechen dieselbe sprache und es ist
egal wie jeder momentan lebt und bei
jedem spüre ich das heimweh viel
miteinander zu
verdis musik wie heil stefko spielte
schon vor dem krieg als erster geiger in
der ungarischen nationalphilharmonie in
budapest seine eltern leben in der
ukraine ihre enkel sehen sie nur noch
per video marco kolonko konnte noch kurz
nach der invasion mit seinen drei
kleinen kindern das land verlassen und
lebt momentan in schweden adrian bottner
kam erst vor wenigen tagen mit dem bus
auslief
es ist eine große ehre für uns denn es
ist mehr als eine tonne es wird erneut
die aufmerksamkeit auf das lenken was
derzeit in der ukraine geschieht oder
von maskulin
[Musik]
terry lynn wilson die kanadische
dirigentin mit den ukrainischen wurzeln
auch ihre cousins kämpfen im donbass das
freedom orchestra war ihre idee
[Musik]
davon habe ich seit der invasion in der
ukraine geträumt solidarität zu zeigen
und für die zukunft der ukraine an der
kultur front zu kämpfen wie green von
der castro fand einen monat lang wird
das orchester durch europäische städte
und new york touren als zeichen gegen
den krieg und nicht zufällig beginnt die
tourneen warschau der stadt die im
zweiten weltkrieg von den deutschen dem
erdboden gleichgemacht wurde
wir bitten unsere ukrainischen freunde
schaut auf uns in warschau und glaubt
dass alles möglich ist laut die städte
wieder auf und füllt sie mit leben es
ist real und es ist machbar
der ukrainische männer wehrfähigen alter
irland derzeit nicht verlassen dürfen
erteilte ihnen präsident sie lenski
einer ausnahmegenehmigung nach der
tournee kehren sie in die ukraine zurück
meine ukrainisch ich habe dort eine
familie kinder außerdem habe ich dort
einen job wir werden auf jeden fall
zurückkehren weil wir glauben dass sich
die situation verbessern wird wir werden
gewinnen es gibt keinen anderen weg
vor gut zwei stunden begann das
gründungskonzept ist ukrainian freedom
orchestra in warschau mit der symphonie
nummer sieben des ukrainers valentin
silvestro der 84 jährige komponist es
vor dem krieg in seinem land nach berlin
geflohen
[Musik]
susanne pohlmann über das ukrainische
freiheits orchester das komplette
konzert können sie sehen in der arte
mediathek und dann ab sonntag am sonntag
im arte fernsehen ab 17 uhr 10
das war unsere welt an diesem
donnerstagmorgen und am wochenende
freuen sich hier grundschule gause und
mitri sirin auf 7 wir sind kommende
woche wieder da und empfehlen ihnen
jetzt noch unser heute schon mal update
gegen 0 uhr 30 mit nazan charakter mehr
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt verdrängt das tief
frieda das hoch mika nach südschweden
das bedeutet regen regen schauer und
gewitter aber heute nacht macht sich
hoch mika in norddeutschland noch
bemerkbar da wird's nämlich kühl da
sinken die temperaturen auf 13 bis 8
grad sonst geht's auf 16 bis 13 grad
runter und schon heute nacht gibt es
gewitter aus den alpen heraus und in der
zweiten nachthälfte ziehen regenschauer
und gewitter über den schwarzwald weiter
nordwärts erreichen dann auch die rhön
und das sauer hat morgen über tag werden
dann diese schauer und gewitter sich
ganz allmählich weiter nach norden
wälzen über den harz hinaus in der
zweiten tageshälfte werden dann neue
gewitter aus den alpen kommen das können
richtige unwetter seien also mit
starkregen verbunden die gewitter das
bringt schon was in sachen regen
immerhin so 10 bis 30 liter pro
quadratmeter und das denkt dann auch die
waldbrandgefahr zumindest mal hier in
bayern sonst gibt es noch
waldbrandgefahrenstufe 4 von 5 die
temperaturen morgen liegen an der
nordsee bei 20 22 grad sonst werden es
23 bis 30 grad und am samstag werden
regenschauer und gewitter deutschland
dann ostwärts verlassen von nordwesten
kommen am sonntag neue regenschauer und
gewitter heran und am montag wird es
dann schon wärmer und wie sie hier am
trend für freiburg im breisgau sehen
können geht es danach mit gedämpfter
sommerwärme weiter allerdings ohne regen
guten abend